le loin et son paysage sont bouleversés
durant les travaux
l'îlot végétalisée fait placer les
pelleteuses qui s'attaque à un barrage
d'une trentaine de mètres
depuis 2008 un inventaire dresse la
liste des ouvrages du bassin versant les
plus impactants pour le milieu sont
détruits il faut vraiment déterminer les
usages de l'ouvragé les enjeux est ce
qu'il ya un enjeu patrimonial par
exemple on peut avoir un très beau
moulin qui serait bien évidemment
inutile de supprimer il faut le
valoriser et donc cet aspect touristique
mais qui devient très rare sur le bassin
mais il ya surtout beaucoup d'ouvragés
qui sont malheureusement maintenant plus
du tout entretenu et c'est donc qu'ils
n'ont plus aucun intérêt pour le pôle
fonctionnement du cours d'eau et dans
ceux dans ce cas là on privilégie la
suppression de lougratte dans les années
70 ce déversoir en béton fut érigée dans
laxe du moulin de châlette sur loing
il permettait de préserver la hauteur
d'eau lorsqu'il était encore en
fonctionnement
aujourd'hui il n'a plus d'utilité après
cinq semaines de travaux le loin va
reprendre progressivement sa liberté
d'écoulement et de déplacement des
sédiments
on a retrouvé des espèces dites ferait
au fil des espèces de courants comme la
vandoise le barbeau etc qui sont des
espèces patrimoniales et donc à partir
de à partir de ce moment là dès lors que
le loin va retrouver sa liberté
d'écoulement il va recréer
des écoulements des habitats naturels
propices à toutes les espèces
patrimoniales durant sept à huit mois
le comportement du loing sera observée
avant toute intervention de l'homme
comme l'aménagement deux banques est
végétalisée et un inventaire piscicole
aura lieu également dans quelques années